so he comes and you know there's no
karate because he's in a halfway house
and
you know he's like kind of come and see
me every day he was in he was in jail
for
bookmaking for numbers and numbers in
those days is the last three numbers of
the track and the paramutual
and it's a cuban lottery you know and uh
started in tampa and then in new york
it's huge that's what my mother did but
that's what this guy did
and they put him in jail now here's the
beauty of this numbers in new jersey
it's a felony
that's where he got arrested in new
jersey it's a felony but right over the
[__] bridge in new york it's a ticket
so all your banks for bookmaking are in
new york city see testicle testaments
they teach you [__] something
too you know what i'm saying
so if you're ever in new york and you
want to play a number [__] it not in
jersey we gotta go to new york
because joey told us is a [__] ticket
so uh
he got caught so big with the numbers
that he wasn't allowed in jersey for a
[__] year
how bad are you when you're not allowed
in a [__] state
you know and he and i didn't know this
i'm like four just want to go to karate
and
the deal was he wasn't a lot in jersey
so the only thing he could do at the
halfway house was come to my our house
and i loved it he [__] would come
over and
teach me how to write and teach me how
to [__] comb my hair and take showers
and
you know he just taught me how to be a
[__] man you know like how to be a
kid the things that your mom can't teach
you
you know you pull the skin back do you
wash your helmet all that [__]
you know what i'm saying you got to wash
your ass he taught me how to fold
clothes he taught me all this [__]
he's put vo5 in my hair and i could look
like a mobster and [__]
you know he taught me how to shave i had
no hair and i would shave
with steam in the shower you know he
just taught me all these things
and he was so gentle with me like he was
such a [__] great guy with me he
would
walk me to school and walk me back from
school and believe it or not that
my first grade year because of him it
was successful in kindergarten
i played hooky like the third day of
kindergarten and i got hit in the head
with a lunch box at central park
and they broke my [__] head i got six
stitches in my head and after that you
know i just kept going so
they were in shock about my behavior but
after he came out of jail
my behavior had to calm down this guy
really worked for me
so now i'm in this i'm going into the
second grade and this is our first
summer together and he's still not
allowed in jersey
so my mother got him a job in one of her
bookmaking operations in the bronx
it was a dry cleaner front and upstairs
was a bookmaking operation he ran the
whole [__] thing with numbers
and his partner in the operation was a
guy named nelson puerto rican guy
he's in jail for 30 years he got
soul-selling grenades to the dea
in like the [__] 80s before my mother
died he sold like a landmine to the
[__] dea
they gave me 8 000 [__] years and put
them under the [__] jail you know
what i'm saying
but i love nelson i love both these
[__] and i would go with them
and
and they would teach me how to like take
clothes and they had the bronx in the
70s was a bad
[__] neighborhood again a bad
[__] neighborhood they had this
german shepherd that was
[__] gigantic his name was killer if
you look at me straight sometimes you
see i got scars on my face
he bit me in the face when i was [__]
five that dog because i tried to take a
piece of [__] ham from him
this guy did not [__] around either
these [__] i was in a league of
[__] tough [__] here right
and i didn't even know it you know juan
was
my stepdad i didn't care what he was or
what he did numbers i knew numbers was
illegal
in some sort my mom did everything
illegal my mother had a [__] alias
so i knew that whatever they were doing
was bad i just as long as i got a gi joe
i don't give a [__] what you do
as long as i go to karate and go to a gi
joe you can [__] kill yourself for
all i give a [__]
you know i didn't really care what they
did so
my mom was a big met fan and this is how
i got to find out about juan who one was
my mom was a big met fan
and we go to the met games just at the
sprite of a [__] hat let's go to a
mec game
and we get in a cab and go to long
island and go to a mec game
and my mom had this planned route that
she would take
you know and she would give the cat my
mom was a beauty she'd give the cab
driver a 20. as soon as she got in the
cab
this is 1970 she'd go that's so there's
no misunderstandings
i don't want no [__] traffic i don't
want nothing i don't care if you got to
cut [__] off
go right to shea stadium and these are
the directions you take cause there's no
traffic it's a quick route
the guy's like no no no i know how to
get you that better the guy gets stuck
in traffic my mother and the guy start
[__] arguing
and my mother's like [__] give me the
20 back and drop me off so when she went
to get the 20 back the guy did something
with his hand and he cut my mother's
face like with a fingernail or something
so you know my mother my mother smeared
the blood on her face right
and she goes pull over [__]
we're gonna get to the bottom of this
and we call the dry cleaner juan was
getting ready because the numbers go
down at three
numbers the banks closed at three so you
go home so it's a part-time job ten to
three
but he would say he would stay out till
seven so we called the dry cleaner
like we had a problem at the met game
what am i six you know maybe
and also juan and nelson pull up in this
[__] car and my mom is arguing with
the cab driver they're about to call the
police
when they call the police and call the
police my stepfather comes out of the
car with nelson they walk up they go
what's the problem here
i'll never forget the guy had glasses on
the cab driver had glasses on
and i was like trying to talk to my dad
like dad he did this to mommy
what the [__] are we gonna do you know i
don't know what he's gonna do
so he goes move back he takes my hand
right here and he goes just move back a
little bit
and he pushes me back like three feet
and with this [__] hand he just
goes and knocks this [__] out
think of hitting somebody on sunset
boulevard that's how [__] he just
knocks this [__] to the floor
glasses come off and he's [__]
kicking him with the narrow kicks
to the midsection and he's [__]
punching him and cars are beeping and
i'm like oh my god i love it let me tell
you something
your father could be the president that
don't mean dick until you see him smack
the [__] out of another man
because when your stepfather beats up
another man you know you're at the right
place you're like
this is my [__] father [__]
well my father's a fireman my father
beat up a [__] in the bronx
yesterday [__] fireman what'd
your father [__] do last night
save a cat [__] my father
bitch-slapped the [__] on
draymond avenue in the [__] bronx in
broad daylight right
guy goes down like a bad habit he gets
back up one my mom's like one you're on
parole the cops
i was like i don't give a [__]
[__] two cop cars pull right up
before that cop got out of the car
i never seen nothing like this in my
life he did something he turned and he
went in his pocket
right and he took like the two top bills
out there were like hundreds
and he ran to the cops as they get out
of the car and he just shook his hand
like he knew the guy what's up bro
this [__] i had to hit him you
know how that goes right the cop feels
the money he's like what what happened
the guy hit you and then they started
talking about baseball
the four cops my stepdad my mother and
nelson
this poor guy's on the floor uh
and that's what i learned about new york
city that's a great place to grow up
right there
you got money you smack somebody the
cops come it's over
and i'm like so wait they're not going
to take you to jail he's like [__] no
and all of a sudden like all right and
the cops are like get up [__]
you know
yeah he was like a healer get up walk
the guy gets up he [__]
on the way home my dad's like my mom's
like you're coming with me [__] you i'm
driving with dad [__]
nobody's gonna [__] slap him in the
face [__] you go away
i was so excited when you see i couldn't
[__] wait to go to karate the next
day and [__] slap [__]
i'm like this is [__] great i'm a kid
my dad just slapped the [__] out of a
[__] on the street
i love this [__] i didn't say no no but
you know you go home and tell your
friends i wasn't allowed
my mom was like don't ever repeat that
dog to your little [__] white friends
because i lived on
i lived on 88th street then i was a
republican block you know what i'm
saying they were nice
so she's like don't say no to nobody